le choix du camp de versailles satory ne
s'est pas fait au hasard même étendue
même largeur le site est similaire à
l'avenue des champs elysées les
conditions sont optimales pour
l'entraînement de l'ensemble des écoles
militaires qui participeront au défilé
du 14 juillet c'est la première journée
ce sont leurs premières répétitions
s'est encore nettement perfectible il
nous reste quatre jours pour obtenir la
perfection comme vous le savez le jour
du 14 juillet ça sera parfait parfait
les officiers n'en doute pas une seconde
la rigueur est de mise les répétitions
se déroule sans accroc ça se passe bien
on le prépare beaucoup et en longuement
sur le long terme
nous le préparons fait en permanence
parce que c'est ça le rôle du soldat
c'est d'être toujours prêt à remplir les
missions qui vous seront confiées
l'engagement c'est le thème de cette
année choisi par le président de la
république pour nous l'engagement c'est
vraiment ça représente le fait de
consacrer sa vie à protéger la nation
c'est faire honneur à la mission qui
nous est confiée
parce que pour nous c'est un honneur de
voir confier la mission de défendre les
intérêts de la france défilé le 14
juillet je ressens ça vraiment comme un
une chance un honneur après seulement
quatre mois de service d'autant plus que
c'est le premier 14 juillet après les
attentats du 13 novembre
donc je suis vraiment très fier et très
enthousiastes de participer au 14 juin
3235 soldats défileront à pied jeudi
accompagné de 210 véhicules
deux cent quarante cavaliers de la garde
républicaine 55 avions et 30
hélicoptères répétition générale mardi
avec ce conseil pour les débutants de
donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes et puis
qu'on arrive à travers à voir à travers
leur manière de dessiner de voir leur
fertier et leur professionnalisme